[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASPER ONONO: The success
of Kola Studios inspired
other people to come
up with-- they inspired
other people to start
up their own ventures.
They are like, this
can really happen.
If Kola Studios did
it, then this is great.
Because Uganda is
an African country.
As you know, Africa
has so many challenges.
There are so many grounds that
haven't yet been covered up,
especially online
payments and stuff.
So I've been seeing a
lot to startups coming
to solve such problems, and
just by the mere success of Kola
Studios, it gives them
the confidence that yeah,
it can be done.
With Matutu, we
discovered there was
a disconnect between
popular games
that were played in the past
and what is currently played,
or there are no games
played at all nowadays.
So we decided to
bring back those games
in the digital world to preserve
the culture and tradition.
We made sure the game
is lightweight and fast,
because looking at the African
market, it's a growing market.
The smartphones
are less powerful.
The internet speeds
are not very good.
So we decided to optimize a
game for the low-end phones.
But that doesn't
mean we-- we don't
compromise in quality for
even the high-end phones.
It's still good enough.
So our game is just
about 5 MB download
in a record seconds,
not even a minute.
So it solves the internet
speeds and maybe the phone
capabilities.